leaders of the nato alliance will meet
in madrid next week a pivotal moment for
european security under the shadow of
russia's war in ukraine
images like these will doubtless be on
their mind the depravity unleashed by
russian forces on the ukrainian town of
butcher has prompted some allies to say
they cannot let a butcher-style atrocity
happen on nato soil
this will mean the biggest overhaul in
nato's defense and deterrence posture
since the cold war aimed at denying
russia the ability to invade
such a move looks set to include the
expansion of a 40 000 strong force on a
higher level of readiness possibly by
six times that number according to two
military sources it's
really important to be able to signal as
a country and as an alliance that yes
you russia can try to attack us and you
may even proceed and attack us but we'll
make sure that you get far less after
the out of the attack than you were
planning
on getting
also part of this new policy will be the
strengthening of eight nato units
already deployed to deter russian
attacks on the alliance's eastern and
south eastern flanks these include the
three baltic states poland romania and
others they could be grown by thousands
of troops but in a key change many of
these new soldiers could be based at
home for example in the uk and be
pre-assigned to a country if needed
it's not just about troop numbers more
military equipment like armored vehicles
possibly air defense systems and other
heavy weapons could be pre-positioned in
front-line baltic states it's a very
opportune moment
and also very crucial moment for the
alliance to stick together to to show
that this is the strongest alliance in
the world not only by words but also by
deeds as well as galvanizing member
states vladimir putin's war has prompted
historically neutral sweden and finland
to ask to join nato
this should be the ultimate signal of
unity that allies could send to the
kremlin but turkey has so far held up
the celebrations because of concerns
about kurdish militants in sweden it's
not yet clear if last-ditch diplomatic
efforts will smooth over the rift in
time for madrid
what is certain though is that this
summit is nato's moment to reshape its
defenses and reduce the chance of
russia's invasion of ukraine escalating
into all-out war across europe